mais qui est donc cet ayrton senna qu'il
y a quinze jours dans le grand prix du
japon avait assuré de façon
époustouflante son premier titre de
champion du monde
caroline cindy n'en dresse le portrait
que le sourire d'ayrton a su qu'à celui
d'un homme qui a enfin atteint son but
il est champion du monde et pour la
première fois de sa vie il est vraiment
heureux depuis 84 d'être de ses débuts
en formule 1 il a tout sacrifié pour ce
titre sa famille ses amis ses relations
avec les autres pilotes
à 28 ans le brésilien est un homme
solitaire renfermé dans sa tête un seul
objectif être le premier
le reste importe peu et ça marche huit
victoires presse pour l'opposition une
saison les records sont battus à son
arrivée chez mclaren cette année il
avait averti je ne viens pas pour être
numéro 2 mais pour gagner un défi pour
lequel il pris tous les risques
menant une véritable guerre contre son
coéquipier alain prost
celui ci dénonce sa froideur son manque
d'humanité
ayrton s'en moque il veut être champion
objectif atteint un premier titre change
un homme
ayrton senna l'a confirmé maintenant je
veux m'amuser soigner mes relations
prendre du plaisir
comment sera le sénat 81,9 toujours
aussi impétueux agressif
en attendant le brésilien veut encore
gagner
adélaïde ma pour la beauté du geste et
il va